hello everyone my name is mona fastwall
and i'm the director of the world to
come and thank you so much for watching
our film
uh joining me today is kathryn waterson
who plays abigail
and vanessa kirby who plays tally and we
have chosen
the scene where abigail and tali
first kiss to to sort of be the center
around what we talk about
so i thought that one of the reasons why
it's exciting to talk about this scene
in particular
is because throughout the film
abigail and halle are constantly
speaking in code and sort of circling
each other
and one thing we worked on a lot with
when are we being understood and when
are we
not being understood and when are we
speaking in code and want to redirect
so um i thought it was interesting to
ask catherine about that in the scene in
particular
and sort of how you decided to approach
this this moment
because what was very fun was that um
prior to shooting this scene
um we had rehearsed it quite a bit
in a different space from where we were
shooting and then
we went to we came to location and we
had a little bit of rehearsal time
the day prior to shooting it and kathryn
and vanessa had a very specific idea
like okay this is what we think we
should do i think we cracked the code on
this
and uh so i would love for you guys to
talk to talk about
uh your process prior to working with me
you know it's so funny because all this
stuff ends up morphing so much over time
and um you know what happened on the day
kind of starts to
morph and blur over time um what i
remember
of that day was
all the doors open in the house and the
feeling how much
um energy that brought into the house
even before vanessa walked in in
the room you know just this feeling that
the seasons were changing that um
there was this energy in this stagnant
space
for the first time and um
and also i remember and i
i speak about this all the time but you
know
my performance lives and dies
on whether my partner has anything to
give me
you know and if if um
if i can just create some kind of
inner calm where i might be able to
notice and hear and appreciate what this
other person is bringing
to the scene i don't feel like i have to
do anything
and in a way that feeling of not having
to do anything
is is what i'm always chasing as an
actor
because it's like the greatest high
you'll ever feel i think
um to be so free
in this imagined world and so
that day
i remember just noticing
without a doubt this woman had walked
into my house in a new way
and she was looking at me in a new way
and i couldn't
she wasn't letting me ignore it
and it was so powerful and what's so
fascinating about a really good actor is
that
i was standing and she was seated so the
force should have been with me
right but this person would sit with
this power
like like a king you know like
i don't have to stand to show how
powerful i am you know what i mean
i'm the king that's what the
overwhelmed with that energy and it was
so
um exciting
but also i had broken my my foot so
it was also that we had to sort of um
embrace the fact that tally would do a
lot of sitting in the film
which actually turn out it's the funny
things that happen on a
film sometimes like the things sometimes
you go like oh this is terrible this is
this i'm not gonna be free and she's
meant to be the freest person in her
body in the space and
she needs to come in and like command
the energy and i for the most part i
couldn't like walk across the space fast
at all i thought it would like hobble so
um i ended up sitting in that chair
in that room a lot but i do remember
it's so interesting it's amazing having
these conversations because you really
get to hear
the other person's side of it but i just
remember thinking why
is it today that tally makes this
decision to come in
and she's going to kiss her today you
know and it and it suddenly dawned on me
like
i don't think it just happens in a
moment out the blue almost unexpected to
tally she's
she's almost too um
what's the right word too sure of things
you know too kind of
i think too visceral a feeling person
you know i think she woke up that
morning
with a feeling and thought i have to do
it today
and there's a kind of it was always a i
felt like a fatalism around her to
i think she was aware that that time
like she didn't have long somehow and i
just remember thinking
i think that's how the scene needs to be
i think tally needs to come in
knowing what she's going to do and all
she has to do is is
let abigail know in one way or another
that that's what's going to happen
and actually so that was such a
beautiful thing to play because
here was catherine being so beautiful
and like uh
shy with me and um you know
was playing this remarkable um
performance of uh playing someone who
didn't really
know how to be looked at you know so it
made it it was such a wonderful thing to
play because i knew i'd come in i sit
down
and all i'd do is just look at her and
she would somehow know if i just kept
with her
you know i wasn't there was like nothing
else going on in that room other than
just
knowing that i needed to let her know
that i was gonna kiss her and it was
going to be soon
and so it was quite like a simple
intention really
and simple motivations and scenes are
always there
sometimes the easiest that makes this
decision yeah
when you have a very you have one thing
that you're working on achieving and
that's what you're working on
and i i think i i was very happy that
you had to be still
i thought that was wonderful for a lot
of these scenes because that you wanted
to move
but you were just always locked at least
to one position and they
actually gave your character uh
a sense of um sort of power and and also
making yourself comfortable in
abigail's home and then i i loved seeing
abigail move around
in your space not knowing what to do
with this person who planted herself in
in your home it was a different dynamic
than what
we maybe would have gone for had you not
you know had you been able to walk
so literally a happy accident
yeah yeah yeah but also i was thinking
just about
what you started with um the quality of
of the script and these um
codes coded language and what we had to
decipher and um and how in scenes like
this one
um the language moves in and
out of very direct
uh direct language and the more
um more coded language that
sometimes in in earlier scenes we see
like kind of whole whole
scenes play out in code um here
the scene begins she says i decided
today i never want to be a
apart away from you yeah which is so
direct
right and then we
then we go into this exchange about our
imagined lives which is somewhat coded
right
like i have these dreams you have these
dreams if i imagine doing something and
i say it's something special
and i say oh i think oh we could have
that
um i think we have that or or we could
have
it right so we're like teetering on the
edge of somewhere between
something coated and something dare we
be a little bit more direct
um and then when the physical comes into
play
it's like all of that code just
crumbles right and it was so exciting
not to play like
why didn't you just do what you were
tempted to do i think is what i say
suddenly we're just saying why didn't
you kiss me just then you know
these two people who've been doing this
dance the whole film of getting to know
each other and trying to figure out
what they feel what the other feels for
them and
and and trying to understand for
ourselves what we're feeling inside
and then suddenly are just like kind of
like two
to teenagers you know falling in love
um and and to sort of ride those waves
um that like were built on the page
is just so exciting
and it was cathartic to shoot it i think
as well
for us after having been dancing around
this for such a long time
and while shooting it as well and then
to
re to literally throw up all the windows
and all the doors
and let all the light in and it's the
first scene of true spring
and then and then shoot the scene was
just like
felt it was deeply satisfying
and then my favorite
improvisation in the movie i think
is catherine bending down
after the kiss to find vanessa's eyes
um to because you're a little bit taller
and you just
you kiss her and you guys kiss and then
you you bend down to really to to
to to be you know to look into her eyes
and to really see her
and um there was something about
that that i thought was just so this
broke my heart
for for the connection that these two
women had and the connection that you
two have
for you you're checking in and you're
looking you when
you want to see her it's not about you
know
it's about the lust and like all those
fun things too but it's also really
about
like you know that moment there it's
like
finding love finding yeah all
of it the joy the like unadulterated joy
of finding finding love
you know having it requited it's like
well you know we know what it's like
yeah gloria's saying
we just you know whenever you know we've
gotten to speak about the film it really
is something that i think
all of us very much connected with was
that this is this love story and we want
to tell
you're going to give these very ordinary
women
a beautiful sweeping exciting
lovely love story you know to celebrate
their
um journey and bravery and you know all
those women who
who dared to to have these amazing
secret wonderful you know moments
together you know sometimes you pull
your hair out all day on set
and eventually get to something you feel
proud of and some days the wind is just
at your back right that day like i just
remember such a flow
you know just it just felt like
and it's not just the three of us right
you know it's the whole crew
it's the energy on set it's this
yeah the sum of all these parts that
um just do make some some days
some days just
what is it i guess a little extra
liberating or something
and just feel safe and free
to play and try things and explore
things and
um and you trust your partner and
you know can really just uh
just find out where you need to go you
know with no
received notion let's just find it
together while the camera's rolling
and it's just the best feeling i'm
feeling this feeling i want to call it
homesickness for
for acting like i'm just i'm missing
that
that's it as we talk about it yeah
no i think i think there's um when
when you get a scene to a really good
place and we would have this very long
very very long scene with scenes with
the two of you that was
you know seven eight pages uh long of
text
a difficult text of period text and
and a lot of that was also finding
finding the movement and like finding
sort of the ballet
of it together with our dp as well and
seeing like how can we
how can we move together and then find
kind of going in and out of um of the
uh you know finding the intent of those
scenes that
that i think was a big challenge also
with the very tough time constraints
that we had on this film
um do you want to talk a little bit
about that vanessa what that was like
for you
the time limit yeah like trying to crack
the code on eight pages and knowing you
had just half a day to do so
yes also because we were shooting on
film so we had a limited amount of film
too
and so there was always a feeling of um
but sometimes that can make you uh i
guess that you have
you have to literally there's an
immediacy to that isn't there because
you go we don't we don't have an option
we might have one take
like let's just try and get it um and
i think sometimes you almost just you
have to put your best foot forward as
much as you can
or not and then be okay with it um
i i do think that the thing that helped
us most to be honest was
pomona your decision to really build the
houses in that kind of landscape
because it really was you know with my
broken ankles in a wheelbarrow
having to get into some seasoning and be
all buried up by the crew
you know and so um
[Music]
there was a like a real ruggedness to
the whole
group and the whole terrain and
that i think like sometimes when my
uncle's better i had to do a long walk
from down the hill to the house that was
at you know abigail's house
and i just remember thinking god this
would be the final little stretch of
maybe a two-hour journey or whatever it
was to
to walk to someone that you wanted to
spend time with
like that you had these snatched moments
with and
those moments like we knew in the film
that we had to have
these moments of just extraordinariness
in these
people's lives it might be the most
they've ever felt or the most alive they
felt or the most um
almost like from a dream really
and that they weren't mostly
ever given permission to be able to feel
like that
um and so i guess this scene
we wanted to try and like somehow
capture that magic you know that like
really sacred moment where suddenly you
just feel like
oh this is something that makes me so
happy and
i can choose to act on it in this moment
come what may you know
and i think that that beautiful line
tally has about like
i dream of this day when women can be
received at home with
with uh what is it cheers and shouts of
joy or whatever like you know
she imagines a world in which she can
choose what makes her happy
and um it felt like that on the day
didn't it felt like okay we just have to
try and
somehow harness that feeling of of
feeling
so alive in someone else's company and
and letting them know that for the first
time
with all this vulnerability and i think
the one thing i remember is i
felt like a teenager and that was quite
surprising to me because tally sort of
feels so
like the more adult one in in the in
their relationship and
more assured and suddenly as her i felt
about 13
14. that's also what's so brilliant
about the
structure of the scene is that you know
she tries to kiss me but ultimately i
kiss her
you know that there is there's this
you know she's the life force she gives
me life right and
then i have life then i have something
to give
and that exchange that
kind of energetic exchange you know that
like brings
again and again throughout the film like
brings life back
to this person who is
um really kind of
holding on by a thread at the beginning
of the film you know like that
that um
kind of look like love as
resuscitation you know
um was really felt i think in that scene
and i keep thinking about the beautiful
line in your in the letter you write
you know and that you beautifully um
recite late in the film which is the way
the way you looked at me when you knew
that you were loved
you know this is like really beaut i
mean
look it's the script right we keep
coming back to these lines that
just
i feel like all three of us our job was
to
to just bring that this lane get to
bring life and energy to this language
it was such a
a constant onset to do it justice
right i mean quite terrifying
yeah nice and i think i think also
and i mean and that was the challenging
you know the challenging part of it as
well
is to to really um to have this text
that could be
that's very beautiful but it can it's
lyrical and we have to
so we constantly had to go back into
what are we really saying and go back
into
just you guys saying the text in a
modern way to one another
and then going back into the uh
and into the into the text that we um
as it was and kind of returning to that
i remember i was very happy that i
could like you know beg steal and borrow
to have two cameras
on that day um you know which was a
luxury we didn't have a lot
um for a long scene and but i was so
happy because i had i'm using
mostly just the the first pick of that
particular scene
yeah i think i remember you saying that
which is so nice because it was like the
first time
yeah you know the first time for the
character done for us
yeah and the first sort of intimate like
really truly physically intimate moment
for the two of you as well
um so all the shyness and the blushing
and everything just i got to capture all
of that
um all right well i think that's
all the time we have so uh thank you so
much for talking to me
about the film and i hope everyone
enjoys